I ever play South Africa no I never I
wanted to go I didn't I was right and
when I flew in there like the lady that
was in charge of the festival said
listen I told you know that and I'd
never heard this before
Asians are third-class citizens and some
white people oh yeah oh I've never heard
of that before
yeah so so I'm telling you right now
like if we play mm see theatres okay and
I did 30 shows to him and the a lot it
was good it was like Pablo Francisco me
here uh Stefanovic
I think she's very funny yes she's mad
funny yeah and uh Ryan stout mo mandel
and Trevor Noah and but this is before
Trevor Noah Trevor Noah
right and um I killed cuz they hell yeah
because they were scared because I was
Asian
right so they put me up first for a
second which was to me like all right
that's great okay you know and I would
go you know like just I just cuz that
you'll do 10 minutes sir so I'll just
condense everything just you know kill
and then we would do meet and greets
afterwards
mm-hm and in front of like just regular
people that paid like extra you know
before the bonus package yeah anything
not mix the VMP not one time did anyone
look at me and say we think you were
funny
alright I would be in front of everyone
and everyone would get compliments and I
would just sit there and not one well
part of South Africa was this that was
enjoy his broke ass so what color was
the audience that P paid for the Vig but
no there are nice people offstage I just
didn't get any compliments and are you
exaggerating this I'm glad I'm glad he
did that I'm glad he challenged me in
that way just now because now you get to
see how he is you get to see what I have
to do
and I'm sayin
are you sure you know let me taste
something do do I call this person do
right and I live life an experience
thing right my soul right right and my
senses mm-hmm and I perceive it in the
most honest way and I related in the
most honest way and for you to challenge
me like that and for the men so you've
never been a little neurotic yes
neurotic he create some times yeah yeah
whoa that's a backstab plan B by the way
don't ever backup plan B I'm planning
he's right about that you're right but I
I'm neurotic yeah so that's what I'm
asking this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
factor my neuroses yeah okay let me say
something right now no last night I did
the improv I did all weekend that they
were running problem right and I know I
know that I'm good I know that my show
was good and I know that when people say
man that was a great show I I go yeah I
know
mm-hmm I really genuinely know all right
there are times it when you see me in
the original room where where I am a
little neurotic because your computer
like it's more of a competition right
there's a lot of comics there you don't
want to you know you just want to save
face right but in this [ __ ]
circumstance in South [ __ ] in [ __ ] up
row right is the real legit [ __ ]
thing man all right so [ __ ] [ __ ] so I
can't ask you a question you can ask me
anything about about if you know roses
came into play
oh maybe maybe was a factor a little bit
but my change
none of it happened
I got [ __ ] every show guys
no I really did experience that and I
got mugged there too yeah I got Magan
sure walked out on my hotel room at like
3 p.m. and you know who in bag is yeah
yeah see in bag goes I'm gonna go across
the street to get something to eat yeah
like a cigarette whatever he was getting
mm-hmm she runs a guard street okay I'll
stay here and this is a like a five-star
hotel all right
it is in Cape Town now mm-hmm all of a
sudden I'm just on the ground oh right
in the hotel no out right outside the
hotel like outside when tourists are
walking by whatever to guys pull me down
onto my belly mm-hmm and one guy has his
knee on my spine and they're rifling
through my pockets
that is crazy
no what are you why did you laugh like
that because it's funny hilarious why
because you're alive when you're here to
tell the story oh that's but but that is
bananas now like I heard about South
Africa and I heard that they assign you
like that people go with you anywhere
like bodyguards yeah so did you guys
have him no so I'm not so I know I'm not
surprised you got robbed
we had this guy who was in charge like
the bodyguard of the whole group oh
that's not enough but during the day you
know you you just figure and I think
they figured they told us what streets
not to go down what not all right but in
the area that we are in in general and
then it was two Africans that black guys
did it right and then you can't go the
please because you're Asian they're not
gonna believe you
or not beer not only that not only that
it's like how do you do you know I mean
like in a second how do you describe
right right you're on your eyes on you
you're on your stomach
yeah yeah so what they take my
blackberry and some cash and no one that
came to your rescue and then people were
just walking by watching this yeah and
then no help or anything
yeah then Ian ran across the street he
saw him yeah I don't think he there's
another thing that I have with him yeah
I think he took a little too long
I think that he watched the whole thing
and then he slowly walked across Mike
young do you yeah you might come to me
and then he was like whatever I go you
saw what happened
Canadian bastard yeah yeah you don't
expect the Canadian to get involved in
that there's no way
[Music]